on va retrouver tout de suite docteur
sylvain tillon il est vice président de
la fédération des médecins
omnipraticiens du québec monsois
d'occasions
on s'attendait à autre chose dont vous
dire vraiment avec ce projet de loi
personnes avaient une idée de ce que ça
allait contenu ou aujourd'hui donc ce
qu'on voit il ya peau du cou de carotte
le bâton là dedans y'a pas de menace de
pénalités on change la proche comme le
disait ma collègue valérie et on veut
forcer les médecins à revoir ensemble
l'organisation du travail dans les gros
patrons de gmf comment vous réagissez
est
sûre les objectifs de fond on se rejoint
sauf que pour nous malheureusement juste
le dépôt d'un projet de loi aussi doux
soit il nous apparaissait être une
mesure inappropriée dans l'état actuel
des discussions qu'on avait plus
gouvernement puis il ya quand même un
risque de démobilisation de nos médecins
sur le terrain de voir qu un projet de
loi de cette nature qui a été déposé
ceci dit comme le dit le ministre dans
les extraits que vous avez passé
l'invitation à la négociation la main
tendue le canevas de travail comme il le
dit nous étions déjà dedans et on
attendait nous un retour du gouvernement
depuis le 21 octobre dernier date à
laquelle on a fait une dernière
proposition pour améliorer l'accès et on
en est toujours en attente est bon ce
qu'on a eu finalement c'est un projet de
loi ce matin ceci dit je crois que la
fédération sans aucun sans aucun doute
vont reprendre la discussion de sourds
demeure disponible pour qu'on soit
capable d'améliorer l'accès aux
québécois pour voir un médecin de
famille oui mais peut-être un autre
professionnel également qu'il pourra
répondre à ses besoins bon on va prendre
ce morceau par morceau si vous voulez
bien vous êtes d'abord il ya peut-être
un risque d'effet démobilisation parce
qu'on passe par un projet de loi mais
que j'ai moi si je me trompe pas ce que
je crois comprendre de ce que dit
aujourd'hui monsieur dubé c'est que il a
accès à de l'information pour savoir
combien de patients à chaque mécène et
c'est il ya pas les noms des médecins le
maintenant pour être capable de donner
cette information leurs directeurs
régionaux de médecine pour que eux qui
gèrent l'ensemble d'une région peut
savoir un portrait mais ça prend des
noms faut savoir qui fait quoi y aller
avec une nouvelle plate forme aussi ça
permet de voir combien
rendez vous se donne et sont distribués
par gmf par clinique médicale donc ce
que je comprends c'est que ça prenait
une loi pour que ce soit légal et pour
permettre cette nouvelle façon de
fonctionner est-ce que c'est exact
premièrement on va compléter une de
notre côté de l'analyse plus fine du
texte de loi là on a des gens qui
travaillent actuellement là dessus pour
ce qui est de votre première de votre
première assertion concernant avoir des
noms oui il ya tout de même actuellement
dans la loi de l'assurance maladie la
grille la régie de l'assurance maladie
du québec des limitations à ce qui peut
à être diffusés en termes de données
nominatives d'un de nos médecins et dans
mon livre à moi je ne suis pas certain
que ces données nominatives pourront
être envoyés dans les établissements
ceci dit ce qu'il ya dans ce projet de
loi là c'est peut-être plus une mesure
est entre autres c'est avec lui que par
le ministre dubé pour la nouvelle
plateforme de prise de rendez-vous qui
aiment nous permettent d'avoir une
meilleure appréciation de l'offre et de
la demande de services médicaux sur le
terrain pour être capable justement
région à région d'avoir une meilleure
idée d'un équilibre du déséquilibre dans
lequel on ait un sens là il ya quand
même le je pense quelque chose
d'intéressant pour qu'on puisse avoir
des données ont pu échanger avec le
gouvernement mais on est loin de données
nominatives à cet égard de madame or ce
qui est intéressant aujourd'hui pour les
patients c'est savoir d'abord le minet
soit venu beaucoup l'accent en disant
inscrivez vous le vous savez on en a 800
mhz et qui sont inscrits mais on pense
qu'en réalité le vrai chiffre c'est un
million et demi de personnes qui sont
les patients orphelins donc il faut
s'inscrire et c'est cette nouvelle
plateforme pour prendre des rendez vous
donc on passera plus soin par bonjour
santé ou soit par plusieurs des
plateformes comme ca ou appelez
directement une clinique il on va tous
concentrés ça comme vous et ce avec
cette question de donner pour l'offre et
la demande les gens ce qu'ils veulent
surtout savoir d'occasions c'est est ce
que là ça va marcher est ce que là ils
vont capable de prendre rendez-vous et
de l'obtenir dans
un certain nombre de jours et ne pas
avoir à attendre 3 ans 4 impasse ramasse
avec des cassettes épouvantable pour
faire renouveler une prescription
l'objectif que l'on visé c'est ce qu'on
a fait comme proposition au gouvernement
c'est d'améliorer l'accès est de
permettre aux gens qui n'ont pas aimé sa
famille d'avoir un endroit où aller
consulter donc si souvent plus qu'on
veut qu'on retrouve dans la composition
là dans le projet de loi puis le
ministre un petit peu l'époque et dans
les différents points de presse kg fait
c'est de dire à un groupe de patients
mais vous attendra pour aller consulter
sa soie dentelle clinique ça rejoint l'
approche que l'on avait ceci dit pile
donc de consulter dans telle clinique et
l'or pourrait avoir accès à des services
oui peut être d'un médecin de famille si
votre besoin et de voir un médecin ami
mais ça pourrait être un autre
professionnel soit une infirmière
pharmacie un travailleur social une
infirmière praticienne spécialisée donc
c'est de faire finalement un accès
dirigé de donner un accès diriger pour
que les patients arrêtent là de faire de
multiples aux appels pour pouvoir et vu
l'entrain des doigts lorsqu'ils ont des
besoins ceci dit le des 800000 des 880
milles patients qui sont actuellement
inscrits puis bon si on prend ce qu'une
fin ce qui les 1.5 millions beaucoup de
ces patients là c'est pas nécessairement
d'avoir accès de d'avoir l'armé de sa
famille mais c'est d'avoir accès à un
médecin famille avoir accès à un médecin
de famille à un groupe de pratique
lorsqu'ils en ont besoin parce qu'ils
ont tous besoin des vues de demain c'est
évident que si on a des représentations
ces patients le vont devoir et vue puis
on est nous deux d'avis que ce qu'on a
fait en propositions au gouvernement le
depuis l'été dernier est de nature à
améliorer c'est assez bon et pour les
sanctions se comprend finalement c'est
que cette porte est un petit peu plus
tard puis on change de méthode c'est pas
par médecin mais c'est par groupe de
médecins qui s'est associé pour
travailler ensemble alors le
gouvernement travaille manifestement ce
moment ils veulent avoir accès à des
données veulent avoir le portrait
complet mais s'ils voient des choses là
dedans qui leur déplaisent s'il voit par
exemple un gmf loi qui reçoit pas
suffisamment de patients au cas des
plages horaires trop restreint et samson
vont finir par venir est ce que vous
comprenez la même chose que moi
effectivement le
le projet de loi tel quand on le lit
quand on fait une première lecture peut
nous apparaître ne pas avoir de mordant
cependant le diable est dans les détails
et dans les différents articles ont fait
référence à des dispositions
réglementaires qui pourront être
adoptées par le gouvernement à cet égard
le nous on a des craintes que un moment
donné le gouvernement veut y aviez avec
une fois davantage coercitives sans
laisser le temps aux terrains de
s'adapter parce que cette mesure le qui
font qu'on discute vous et moi d'aproz
collective on sort un peu de
l'inscription individus et leurs
patients un médecin mais davantage une
approche collective un groupe de
patients a perçu un groupe de pratique
ben ça prend quand même un certain temps
la fois qu'on donne du temps au temps
certainement pas des années mais pour
pouvoir quand même qu' on puisse avoir
le temps de faire bouger un peu les
indicateurs pour voir que cet axe-là
était effectivement donné et comme je le
disais oui c'est le groupe de pratiques
megatel d'autres professionnels en
dehors de nos milieux tri décante
pourquoi voir un médecin quand on a
quand on soigne blessures sportives
qu'on pourra aller en physiothérapie
sans voir un médecin voire une
nutritionniste la même chose l'accès aux
pharmaciens est également quelque chose
qui existe déjà mais qui pourrait
peut-être davantage développer la partie
1 qui prend rendez vous avec son avec
son médecin pour discuter des effets
secondaires de sa médication ça peut
être réglé avec son pharmacien qui le
cas échéant l'autre optionnel pour
rentrer en contact avec un médecin ou le
référé au groupe de pratiquer leur vers
lequel le patient est orienté merci
beaucoup d'occasions pour cette entrevue
ce soir avec plaisir enfin pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici r d
oh